je reçois maintenant philip morris
[Musique]
bonjour bonsoir bonsoir
philip morris bonsoir pour soins donc
j'ai été condamné à mort en 1991 pour le
meurtre d'un policier grâcié par
françois mitterrand en 1981
votre peine a été commuée en prison à
perpétuité vous ai passé 23 ans derrière
les barreaux la moitié de votre vie est
là en prison vous devenez un grand
spécialiste de l'histoire médiévale ou
fait une thèse sur la famille en
gévaudan au xvème siècle et avec mention
ou publier un livre pour raconter votre
histoire qui était extraordinaire
ça s'appelle de la haine à la vie c'est
aux éditions du cherche midi
voilà alors j'imagine que quand vous
êtes sorti de prison il ya un an
vous aviez aucune envie d'écrire un
livre sur ce sujet vous l'avez fait pour
soutenir la les abolitionnistes parce
que vous êtes un bel exemple contre la
peine de mort en tous les cas en fait
donc le faîtage ne voulais pas
spécialement écrire de livres bon on a
fini par me solliciter par et
ce n'est pas mon histoire que j'ai écrit
même si même si c'est une partie de mon
existence c'est plutôt un une expérience
dont j'ai voulu faire part dans la
mesure où le problème qui m'intéresse le
plus c'est celui des jeunes qui
aujourd'hui dans les banlieues sont les
jeunes qui sont exposés à toutes sortes
de problèmes et qu'ils peuvent faire de
mauvais choix de vins et des choix qui
vont les mener à la prison et qui vont
parfois les confronter à une escalade
escalade à laquelle chez je me suis
livré à moi-même
alors pour éviter les reproches qui
pourrait vous êtes fait parce que c'est
vrai qu'avec celui va marcher
c'est évident et que vous avez en vendre
beaucoup vous à gagner de l'argent j'ai
décidé d'en donner une grosse partie aux
familles des victimes en fait il n'y
aura pas d'argent pour moi quasiment pas
du moins l'argent va aller aux partis
s'ils viennent donc aux victimes aux
familles des victimes
et puis au fisc puisque ce qui me semble
un peu aberrant qu elle mais n'ayant pas
de revenu je trouve aberrant de devoir
payer de l'argent au fisc alors qu'il
serait mieux que la totalité aille aux
familles de victimes alors dorothée vous
parlais pas beaucoup quand même du
policier que vous avez tué c'est
pourquoi je ne souhaitais pas chercher
quelque chose qui soit sensationnel je
ne voulais pas bon il ya cela et puis
en fait il est vrai que je n'avait sans
doute pas envie d'extraire de moi
une partie enfin cette partie là et vous
y pensez souvent c'était bidon de toute
façon quand quand on a une vie comme la
mienne quand on s'est fourvoyé comme moi
il est bien évident que les choses sont
là et maintenant au delà de cela il est
bien évident que mon passé
est irréparable et mon passé je le porte
clés en moins il ne s'éteindra pas le
passé et inexpiable c'est à dire vous
par exemple vous vous excusez pas auprès
des familles de la victime parce que
vous pensez que le pardon serait
ridicule dans une situation pareille de
toute façon je pense que
je pense que parfois il serait insultant
de demander à quelqu'un de me décharger
de ce qu'il ya en moi ouais ce qu'il est
en moi je dois le jeu doit le garder on
parlait pas non plus de l' avocate
stagiaire qui vous avez fait passer une
arme en prison à un moment un moment
vous vouliez vous évadez vous êtes fait
attraper vous n'avez pas pu vous évader
sa carrière a été brisée vous en parlez
pas non plus alors pour une bonne raison
c'est quelqu'un j'en parle très peu dans
le livre le moins possible c'est
quelqu'un qui a aujourd'hui refait sa
vie et qui ne souhaitent pas du tout que
l'on parle d'accord et donc voilà c'est
le fait c'est important de l'allier se
bat non non bien fonctionné pas qu'est
ce qu'elle veut c'est quelqu'un qui ne
souhaitent pas du tout que l'on parle
d'elle
alors faut dire quelque chose votre père
était policier en fait souvent dans les
articles dans la presse on l'a dit tiens
le fils d'un policier etc
en fait votre père a quitté le foyer
familial à ces jeunes donc ça n'a pas
grand chose à voir le fait non mes
parents ont divorcé j'avais 6 ans il n'y
a jamais eu de problème d'ailleurs entre
mon père et à et moi même a lancé le
ça n'a rien à voir le fait alors vous
êtes en contact avec la marginalité
assez du tout parce que votre frère est
emprisonné pour une histoire de trafic
de voitures
vous lui rendez visite en secret et là
vous commencez à sentir ce goût un petit
peu du légalité de la marginalité au
départ pour aider votre frère plus
simplement parce qu'il voulait s'évader
donc voulu aller le voir
et là vous vous mettez le doigt dans
l'engrenage d'une certaine façon alors
moi j'ai trouvé totalement anormal que
mon frère soit soit mis en prison
j'aimais mon frère en outre il avait été
interpellé dans une affaire dans
laquelle se trouvait
à membres du sac service d'action
civique est cette personne
elle n'a jamais été mise en prison je
veux pas dire ça n'aurait servi à rien
que cette personne soit mise en prison
mais en tout cas mon frère y était
j'avais une injustice qui vous est de
toute façon déjà révoltés bon ça c'est
un miroir mon frère voulait s'évader à
partir de là je trouvais normal de
l'aider à s'évader
dès lors il est vrai qu'on est pas son
frère à s'évader de prison en allons
travailler comme aide comptable et donc
j'ai mis le pied dans l'engrenage est
alors j'ai rencontré des personnes j'ai
découvert aussi
une forme de belvis à savoir que en
banlieue
l'argent les produits de luxe n'existe
pas tellement
et là dans cette ville a bien sûr je
découvrais des boutiques comme fauchon
découvrait des hôtels agréable je
découvrais les belles voitures et il est
vrai que tout en commençant à aider mon
frère je découvrais une autre vie dans
laquelle il était agréable de cette
situation alors 77 vous finissez par
être incarcéré enfin à rodez d'abord
quelques mois à rodez et ensuite à la
prison de la santé
il a effectivement ça a été le
basculement vous êtes passé à tabac
quand vous arrivez à la santé il ouvre
les fenêtres il voulait ce parterre vous
êtes bleus de froid légende le sexe
partout bleus de froid et une photo de
votre fiancée quand vous revenez il ya
quelqu'un qui a marché volontairement
sur la photo est là dans celle que vous
voyez des gens en uniforme qui ne
respectent pas la loi c'est à dire que
jusqu'à présent vous aviez quand même le
sentiment que la société devait se faire
respecter et que les gens qui la faisait
respecter soit en uniforme et vous
basculez quand vous avez une vingtaine
d'années et que des gens comme ça vous
des gens en uniforme route coup on casse
quelque chose d'autre on place on casse
quelque chose qui se trouve dans votre
tête et j'ai écrit dans le livre que ce
jour là il avait tué je sais plus si
j'ai dit l'enfant ou le gosse
et c'est vrai qu'à partir de ce moment
là beaucoup de choses basculent la seule
chose qui me retenait encore c'était
l'amour j'avais ma fiancée que j'aimais
qui m'aimait encore et je me suis
accroché à cela avec beaucoup de force
la force du désespoir fin août
malheureusement quand on doit passer
quatre ans en prison très souvent
l'amour s'émousse et quand l'amour
disparaît pour moi en tout cas il n'y
avait plus rien plus rien note
il y avait que la volonté de ne plus
rester en prison voilà volonté d'en
sortir et s'en tire par tous les moyens
alors richard berry c'est je pense à ce
que vous avez fait un film avec bord
âgés qui s'appelle l'addition de nyama
où effectivement c'est un rapport comme
ça entre le le prisonnier le matin et le
matin mais c'est c'est malheureusement
assez souvent le le sort de beaucoup de
détenus qui débarque pour peu qu'ils
soient un petit peu insolent ça arrive
souvent il faut dire aussi que le
travail des matons et injuste mais rible
justement ce que je vais dire ces
dernières il faut respecter aussi
beaucoup ce travail fasoli ni disait en
68 les vrais prolétaires c'est pas les
étudiants évidemment parce que c'était
comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs c'est vrai que les vrais
polonais les étudiants qui manifestaient
c'étaient les petits bourgeois c'est la
majorité silencieuse états unis disaient
les vrais prolétaires c'est les crs bien
sûr et c'est vrai que ils sont enfermés
aussi les matons le gardien de prison
qui fait son métier
oui il n'y a rien à lui reprocher quand
il fait son métier
le problème c'est quand il
commet des actes qui n'ont rien à voir
avec son travail est malheureusement tel
que le système existe il n'ya pas
bonnard est bastonné un homme dans une
dans une cellule ce n'est pas normal lui
infliger d'autres brumath vous citiez
tout à l'heure l'exemple de la photo
piétiner volontairement mais il y en a
plein comme ça de et tout cela ce n'est
pas normal
et là il devrait y avoir sanction or le
système couvre et un détenu qui est roué
de coups et qui porte plainte
voilà c'est ça il porte plainte et alors
la procédure a été abandonnée car les
témoins certifié qu'il ne s'était rien
passé l'était moins c'était ce qui
allait l'arrière du cou et ses cascades
kafka les bains lorsque
il y à des gardiens qui sont des adeptes
de la violence
celui qui n'en est pas adeptes il est
quand même obligé de faire semblant
parce que sinon il n'est pas solidaire
du corps et il s'exclut lui même mais le
problème c'est que l'institution permet
que cela se passait donc il faut
réformer l'institution
il faut réformer il faut donner fixé un
but à la prison il faut dire aux
gardiens comment ils doivent travailler
il faut leur donner une déontologie et à
partir de là les choses seraient très
différents est ce qu'il n'était pas
comme ça avec vous parce que vous aviez
but est un flic
parce que c'est quand même on se fait là
la rage qu'il y a eu à mon encontre de
la perdre un gardien ne vient pas de là
elle vient d'une tentative d'évasion que
que j'ai tenté alors que j'étais
condamné à mort voilà je l'attendais
d'être exécutée j'ai tenté un malade et
cela raté et cela échoue et du moins et
j'ai blessé un gardien en tentant de
partir
bon à la base et nous voulons continuer
l'histoire de comportement vous subissez
ces vexations ces brimades vous est
rongé par la haine parce que c'est vrai
que la haine dans ces moments là c'est
un moyen de survie c'est le seul moteur
qui vous restent ceux l'énergie qui vous
reste c'est la haine alors ça fait vivre
et ça détruit ça ronge de l'intérieur en
même temps la haine c'est quand on a une
véritable haine en soit ce qu'il ya de
terrible c'est que c'est très douloureux
la haine fait physiquement mal la haine
la haine je la compare un peu à un
ulcère un ulcère très très virulent et
donc et d'un autre côté c'est vrai
qu'elle permet aussi de vivre elle
permet de supporter le
le mur que l'on vous oppose les
vexations que l'on vous inflige un jour
je me suis rendu compte que 7 n était d
très destructrice pour moi est très
dangereuse parce que lorsque vous voyez
c'est comme ça le jour où en face de
vous vous avez quelqu'un qui vous
inflige une brimade vous risquez de ne
pas pouvoir vous contrôlez et donc vous
devenez dangereux pour les autres en
plus de vous détruire et à partir de ce
moment-là il y à un moment où moi je me
suis dit bon il faut arriver à désarmer
cette n1 avant ça justement avant ça et
cette attente de la mort parce que c'est
vrai vous êtes dans le couloir de la
mort comme on dit en parlant des dés
qu'on avait à mort américain c'est à
dire que toute heure qui passe vous
rapproche inexorablement de la mort mais
on fait tout ce qu'on peut évidemment
pour le garder en vie donc ça devient
absurde c'est à dire que par exemple
qu'on vous cessez de vous alimentez on
vous alimente de force
il ya un dialogue surréaliste avec un
médecin de fresnes qui dit je dois vous
maintenir en vie pour qu'on puisse vous
exécutez donc c'est devient kafkaïen
encore une fois - et le condamner à mort
n'a pas le droit de se suicider ouais il
n'a pas le droit de tuer non plus
autrement c'est à dire que la suite de
ma tentative d'évasion bien sûr le
personnel m'en voulait énormément et
et certains avaient envie de
en fait j'ai même un peu peut-être
failli tuer quand j'ai échoué mais mais
les ordres ont été donnés pour ne
surtout pas me tuer ouais il fallait que
je dis tu voilà donc la main en 80 donc
giscard d'estaing hésite
les élections arrivent il sait pas très
bien ce qu'il faut faire c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque vous dira peut-être encore le
cas maintenant mais la majorité de la
population française était favorable à
la peine de mort et mitterrand a pris
une décision très très courageuse
puisque c'était pas démagogique pour le
coup donc lui voue grassi et et vous
dites choses extraordinaires vite avant
d'être graciés je considérais que
j'avais des droits face à des gens qui
allaient me couper en morceaux comment
vous est gracié vous n'avez plus droit à
la violence et c'est peut-être là
effectivement vous commencez à échapper
à la haine non à partir du moment où on
me laisser vivre il était bien évident
que je ne pouvais plus me permettre tout
ce que seraient les mêmes raisons de
faire en tous les cas oui dans la vôtre
peine donc à commuer en prison à
perpétuité d'abord dans un cul hs
ensuite une détention normale
et là vous parvenez à canaliser votre
haine votre énergie votre vie pour pour
l'histoire vous faites vous lancer dans
l'histoire alors pour les gardiens c'est
très bien parce qu'un détenu qui
travaillent déjà à l'étude qui se
gardent tout seul donc ça c'est pour eux
c'est évidemment beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus facile et vous vous évadez vous
finissez par comprendre que la meilleure
façon de vous évader c'est pas par la
fenêtre c'est dans les livres mais
disons que à partir du moment où j'ai je
me suis rendu compte donc cet ol devait
être éteintes
bon j'avais quand même déjà fait une
dizaine d'années
j'avais atteint déjà un à jour de
l'étude j'étais à peu près au niveau de
la maîtrise et je me suis rendu compte
que ma vie que j'aurais souhaité
voire être différente je me suis rendu
compte que je pouvais aussi la
réorienter et que j'en avais les moyens
donc donc à partir de là j'ai cessé de
calculer la hauteur des murs pour
essayer de les escalader et je me suis
résigné à purger ma peine jusqu'au bout
avec toutefois une difficulté c'est
qu'une peine perpétuelle on en connaît
jamais le bout je suis aujourd'hui libre
donc au bout de 23 ans de prison mais je
pourrais encore être à l'intérieur pour
une période de 10 ans berne est en
liberté conditionnelle dans une certaine
transiger en liberté conditionnelle
pendant dix ans mais alors la bon vous
travaillez c'est à dire ses heures par
jour vous étudiez des tas de bouquins
500 livres à lorsque fin drôle sais pas
si c'est drôlement fasse que c'est que
le règlement vous interdit d'avoir plus
de dix livres dans votre cellule alors
voulu trafic des livres il colle dès que
ces gens semblent plusieurs que sèche
pour en faire un seul donc la boum
tout ça pour avoir le plus de livres
possible d'entrer parce que les études
qui faisait sa demande d'aidé des tas de
bouquins et puis vous commencez à être
mieux considérer mieux traités à ce
moment là aussi par le personnel
pénitentiaire
d'une certaine façon vous êtes un peu
élargie disons bien que jusqu'à la fin
il ya une chose que vous racontez c'est
qu'à la fin donc au dernier moment le
dernier jour ils vous font encore
attendre une heure par une espèce de
brimades comme ça il devait sortir quoi
en fait j'avais demandé à quelle heure
je sortais puisque je travaillais dehors
le jour je travaillais j'avais donc
demander à quelle heure je sortais pour
pouvoir me rendre à mon travail et une
collègue de bureau est venu me chercher
à l'heure dite et le fait elle leur dit
et bien
on m'a fait savoir au dernier moment que
ça serait pas cette heure-là on a
enfermé dans une cellule alors que la
levée d'écrou était fait que tout était
fait je pouvais sortir mais on m'a
maintenu là et on m'a bien fait
comprendre que c'était un acte
volontaire votre livre a beaucoup de
succès il est très apprécié on en parle
beaucoup et pourtant vous avez pas vous
dit très très clairement vocation à
devenir le condamner à mort des médias
quoi c'est à dire voulait bien être
utile pour faire passer un certain
nombre de messages mais pas non plus
faire que ça c'est à dire que là dans
quinze jours vous allez retourner à
l'anonymat de vos recherches
je suis je suis historien je prépare une
bio sur guillaume le conquérant et en
fait c'est quand même c'est quand même
votre bon sens c'est mon travail
voilà vous êtes devenu le symbole est
aujourd'hui le symbole des gens qui
disent voyait la peine de mort a été
abolie c'est bien regarder on peut
s'amender on peut on peut on peut s'en
sortir vraiment vu naître l'exemple est
vraiment le pire ce serait que vous
rechute y est déjà moi je ne me sens pas
vraiment un symbole mais je peux
comprendre je comprends que pour
d'autres je sois un cas un cas quoi mais
au-delà de ça ça ne me gêne pas dans la
mesure où ma vie mes choix de vie sont
même très anciens si vous voulez à
l'intérieur
donc en prison j'avais déjà fait j'ai
fait mes choix depuis plusieurs années
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de problème
est ce que vous avez envie
richard de poser une question à philippe
mangou
mais c'est clair que j'aimerais bien lui
parler oui mais c'est les questions
questions
voilà bien un philip morris merci de ce
témoignage
on va vous laisser partir merci d'être
venu témoigner richard si vous voulez
discuter
oui allez-y en sont d'accord si vous
êtes d'accord vous avez parlé tous les
deux dans les loges au revoir merci
allait enfin les cours est sûr de ne
rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux